sin duda alguna Messi ya puede decir que
es el mejor de la historia yo lo digo
así de Franco un jugador que tiene 10
ligas siete balones de oro cuatro ligas
de Campeones y ahora un mundial sin duda
alguna está a la altura de decir que es
el mejor de todos los tiempos y ganar un
mundial sobre todo en esta época en un
fútbol que hoy en día yo
desgraciadamente no pude ver Muchos
mundiales pero este fútbol de hoy en día
que es tan físico tan técnico también
que es tan exigente ganarlo de esta
manera creo que le da todos los méritos
a Messi para por fin decir que es el
mejor del mundo y además después del
mundial que ha hecho o en el partido si
miramos es muy poco lo que Messi hizo
mal en el partido siempre estuvo ahí
presionó muchísimo los goles las
asistencias es un mundial demasiado
completo a Messi desde los futbolístico
desde estas cifras desde ser el que
desbordaba el que siempre buscaba el
pase y cuando no tenía el pase buscaba
terminar la jugada eso ha sido demasiado
determinante para este mes y obviamente
transmitirle al equipo esa necesidad de
tener que ganar este mundial porque para
que Messi haya dicho en la antesala de
esta copa mundo este va a ser mi último
mundial era una manera yo creo que de
seguir presionando entre comillas a sus
compañeros y decirle esta Va a ser la
última oportunidad que tengo de ganar
este mundial Ayúdenme y los compañeros
completamente estuvieron en esa misma
sintonía de conseguir para él esa